-My first guest is an Emmy
and Golden Globe-nominated
actress
who stars alongside Jodie Foster
in the new movie
"The Mauritanian,"
which is in theaters now
and on demand March 2nd.
Here's one of our favorites,
Shailene Woodley, everybody.
Hi.
-Hi!
-It is so nice to see you,
buddy.
Thanks so much
for coming back to our show.
I appreciate it.
-Yeah, thanks for having me.
-I want to talk to you
about "The Mauritanian."
You're fantastic in it,
but before we get into that,
I have a lot of questions.
One is that I keep reading
that you are engaged to football
great Aaron Rodgers.
Is that -- Is that true?
Are congratulations in order?
-I mean,
I've been reading that, too,
which is kind --
it's kind of funny.
-Yeah.
-Yes, we are engaged.
We are engaged.
But for us, it's not new news,
you know?
So it's kind of funny.
Everybody right now
is freaking out over it,
and we're like,
"Yeah, we've been engaged
for a while."
[ Chuckles ]
-I love that!
-Yeah, we -- we got engaged
a while ago, and it's been --
He's, first off,
just a wonderful,
incredible human being,
but I never thought
I'd be engaged to somebody
who threw balls for a living.
Like, I never thought
as a little girl, I was like,
"Yeah, when I grow up, I'm gonna
marry someone who throws balls.
Yeah!"
-[ Laughs ]
-But he's really
just so good at it.
And I'm impressed.
-He really knows
how to throw a ball, yeah.
-He can throw fastballs,
he can throw slowballs,
high balls, low balls.
When I first met him,
I think my dog --
My dog like pulled me aside
and was like,
"If you don't date this dude,
I will disown you as my mother
because the 3 -- like,
the 3 feet that I run with you
when you throw a ball is nothing
compared to the marathon
I'm able to run with him."
-Oh, I can't even imagine.
I mean he's --
Honestly, he's been on the show
a bunch of times,
so please give him our best.
He's one of the greatest players
to ever play the game.
Have you spent much time
in Green Bay,
and are you a football fan?
-I -- I still have never been
to a football game,
because we met
during this wacky, wacky time,
and all of the stadiums
were closed
that he was playing in.
So I have yet to go
to a football game.
Before I met him, I'd never seen
one football game before.
I just didn't -- I didn't
really grow up with sports,
especially American sports.
It was never really on my radar,
and so all of --
When we met, also, like,
I knew he was a football guy,
but I didn't know,
like, what kind
of a football guy he was.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And I'm still
constantly learning.
I'm still like, "Oh, wow!"
You know, friends and --
"You got to watch
his YouTube greatest or --"
And I was like, "I don't --
I don't get it.
He's good, he's great."
-Yeah, he's really good.
-Like, I don't --
I don't understand.
-That's so funny.
-Because I don't know him
as a football guy.
I know him as like the nerd
who wants to host "Jeopardy!"
You know, like,
that's the dude I know.
-He loves "Jeopardy!"?
I love that.
-He just happens to also
be very good at sports.
-Yeah. Well, that's so --
that's so great for you.
I'm so happy for you.
You know, enjoy this time.
But I also heard
about another thing,
that you took a trip
to Patagonia,
actually even
during COVID, right?
Kind of recently?
-I did.
-What brought you there,
and how did you get to do that?
-I went in December,
which was a feat.
I mean, the reason I was able
to go there was because
of work permits and whatnot,
and I kind of got in and got out
before Chile
shut down its borders.
But the whole thing was wild.
Like, I landed,
and they check your temperature,
and they were like,
"Oh, you have a fever.
You have to get
back on a plane to America."
-Wow.
-And I was like, "No, no, no!
Like, I just --
I was wearing a turtleneck
on the plane."
So I cooled off,
and they checked it again,
and they were like,
"You're fine."
-How long is the flight?
-It was four flights
to get there.
-Yeah.
-Because we took --
I took a plane from Green Bay
and then a plane from Miami
and then a plane from the main
city in Chile to the second --
to a smaller city in Chile.
Then we got off the plane,
and we drove for a few hours.
Then we got on a boat
and went up a river
for 45 minutes or something
like that in pouring rain.
-And then they're like,
"You gotta go back to America."
And you're like, "No, no, no,
hold on a sec."
-Yeah, it was wild.
I mean, we were
in the middle of --
we were in a community of people
who the only access they have
to their homes is via river.
There's no roads in or out.
So if they want to buy anything,
to bring nails to build a shed,
they have to travel by boat
up and down the river.
I was down there because there's
this company called Karun
that I have just been
completely blown away by.
They empower these local people
to become entrepreneurs,
and at the same time,
they collect plastics and metals
and then they turn them
into eyewear.
So, it's the world's first
100% sustainable,
reusable, renewable...
-Wow.
-...eyewear company.
And it's just --
It's beautiful.
And Patagonia, by the way,
is one of the --
You feel like
you're on the end of the world.
It's so sunny, and the nature is
so well-preserved and pristine.
It's a magical place,
if you've never been.
-I do want to go.
I'm gonna wait
till COVID's over,
and I'm gonna wait till
the flight is only
like two hours.
-Yeah.
-If that's ever possible.
Let's talk about your new movie,
"The Mauritanian."
Can you set up what it's about,
and what drew you to this?
-Yes. So, this is a film
that's based on a true story
about a man
named Mohamedou Salahi,
who was held in Guantanamo Bay
for over a decade
even though
he was found innocent.
He was held in Guantanamo
without a trial.
And it's the story
about the lawyers
on both sides of the equation --
his lawyers as well as
the lawyers
from the United States --
helping this man find a trial,
go through the trial,
and then ultimately have him be
released from Guantanamo Bay.
-Whew.
-Light subject.
Very light subject.
-Yeah, I mean, can you imagine?
I mean, oh, my gosh.
What has to go --
Everything involved with that.
-You know, Jodie Foster
is in the film with me,
and she said the other day,
she was like,
"We all have a lot to learn from
him," and I completely agree.
So I hope
when people see this movie,
they don't just take away
the tragedy of what --
what the circumstances
but also the humanity
behind this man's strength
and his will to survive,
and not just survive
but survive in, like,
a really beautiful
and profound way.
-How is Jodie Foster?
She's just the coolest ever,
right?
-I was gonna
say something sarcastic
and pretend like she wasn't,
but she is.
-Yeah.
-She is --
You just can't.
You can't do that with Jodie.
-I know, you can't.
Yeah, she's just --
-I mean, she is.
She's the -- She's the coolest.
-And a pro.
-She's a pro.
She's -- I learned so much
from being around her.
I mean, I think the thing
that moves me the most
about Jodie is she just loves
what she does, and she's --
and she does it for what I would
feel like are the right reasons.
And she uplifts
every environment that she's in
because she stays --
she remains curious,
and she asks questions that
I think a lot of people's minds
wouldn't even dare
to be curious about.
And in that regard, I just,
you know, again, humanity,
we all have a lot to learn
from Jodie Foster, as well.
-There's no one cooler.
The whole cast is great.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Shailene Woodley
and Jodie Foster
in "The Mauritanian."
Take a look.
-What's your point?
-He's guilty!
He's [bleep] guilty!
-Maybe he is.
He still has a right to counsel.
-I'm not saying that he doesn't.
I'm saying that he helped
to kill 3,000 civilians,
and we're doing everything
we can to get him out.
-We're doing our job.
-I did bake sales
for his legal fund.
That's not a part of my job.
My dad told me I'm not welcome
home for Thanksgiving this year.
That's not a part of my job.
-Get out.
-What?
-You want turkey and pumpkin pie
with mom and dad and Uncle Joe?
Go on, get out.
Go home.
You can't win a case...
if you don't believe
your own [bleep]
-I'm not trying to leave.
I'm just --
-Stop [bleep]
wasting my time.
Get out.
-Shailene Woodley.
"The Mauritanian"
is in theaters now
and on demand March 2nd.